c'est l'aboutissement de huit mois de
travail ces collégiens sont devenus le
temps d'une année scolaire scénariste et
dessinateur de bandes dessinées
j'ai déjà envie depuis longtemps de
faire un métier dans le dessin donc
bassam à particules c'est un projet en
vue que ça lui permettait de plus
participé et puis tout le monde peut y
participer il fallait pas connaître une
réponse vous proposer nos idées etc
c'était vraiment bien le storyboard
c'était sympa à faire en place avec mme
suire ans on est toutes les idées qui
sont trop choqué c'était sympa du coup
de voir les plans ces défis au tableau
un travail réalisé en classe dans deux
établissements yves binois blaise pascal
de plaisir et georges pompidou à orgerus
97 élèves ont planché sur le thème
fantastique en cours de français et
d'arts plastiques ce que traverse et que
ça les a soudés
ç'a permis aux classes d'être vraiment
avoir une cohésion dynamique
intéressante
après il ya des élèves qui ont des
talents naturels pour le dessin qu'on se
sent évidemment très épanouie dans la
dans ce projet au contraire été plus en
difficulté mais qui n'ont pas pour
autant été laissé son bord du chemin
le projet a été pensé par la ville de
buc est soutenu par le département des
yvelines
les quatre classes ont été encadrés par
un auteur reconnu marc védrines auteurs
d'islandia forces spéciales quand on ne
met pas du métier on réalise pas à quel
point
réaliser une bande dessinée ça demande
beaucoup de rigueur beaucoup de travail
et en recherche de documentation de
costumes il ya des histoires qui sont
moment qui se passe en 1870 il faut
faire des recherche de décors de
costumes tout ça comme leurs illustres
aînés ces apprentis bédéiste exposeront
voir dédicaceront leurs créations lors
du festival qui se tient les 12 et 13
octobre